Okay.
Hello folks.
Back for an afternoon stream.
Not too long. Hour and a half, maybe two
hours. Um,
pretty much I Just want to see if we can
get the M running end to end.
This is uh the client M, the one that
happens to be open source. I'd like to
have them a full prototype done so they
can start playing with it because I've
got some other work that needs to be
done over the rest of this week. So
ideally I get them something they can
start uh they can start playing with.
Now let us see what we can do.
I believe if we just do
Oh, right. This container needs to be
rebooted real quick.
So, no idea what messed up with this
before, but we should be fine.
Well, I have no idea what's up with that
SPS.
Uh, that is a 19 second breakout. Wait.
Oh, I'm on the wrong branch. I see.
That is super weird.
I was going to say otherwise that would
be really weird.
All right, that's more like it. 36 37
mil.
No. No, we cannot.
Um, yeah. So, what we're going to do,
we're just going to rebuild.
All right, that's all I need. That is
all I need to debug.
The uh the plan right now we're going to
continue on this environment. It's a
client end that happens to be open
source. It is a commerce uh like a cloud
compute commerce simulator
pricing buying and selling. Uh the only
reason I can do this on stream is the
client decided to open source it. So
cool on them.
and I am working on some updates and
fixes for them. And the new version is
just now getting bound back to puffer
lip. And we have a few little bugs to
fix.
Nothing too difficult.
Yeah. So, right here, this numbum buyers
got scripted buyers. We've got AI
buyers.
So then I what I should do is let's um
let's add some asserts so that we don't
do this again.
So, AI sellers will be
uh one buyers will be one. This will be
zero.
Sound good?
We got more bugs.
Keep a buffer overflow.
And yeah, we got to It looks like we've
got to improve uh we got to fix the OBS
generation as well.
No big deal. So yeah, let's look at what
the OB size is supposed to be. Well,
I changed several things.
Yo, I'm working on old school M. You
ever played
my guy?
Hang on one moment. Actually,
Yeah. Okay, let's do it this way.
Here you go.
This is my account. And there you go.
I do also have the dusted omelette in
the house.
That is my game, my guy. That game
inspired my old PhD.
It turns out that Old School is like the
best freaking game ever for RL.
You're not going to be able to make a
whole end out of it. That's actually
fast. Uh you can do individual bosses
though very effectively.
I've actually I've been um my fun thing
off stream lately has been I've been
learning Doom of Mattal.
Been learning that boss. Got spooned to
2KC. the eye of Ajak, by the way. Um,
but I've been trying to get to to wave
eight and after. And uh, you know, it's
as hard as that thing is, I guarantee
you you make a good sim for that. Puffer
li will crush that in one minute. One
minute of training, it'll do that boss
perfect.
Yeah, the system of that game is just so
good for testing RL.
Top not top 100 ladder account. That's a
little sweaty. Top 1% though, I'd say.
How many accounts have Inferno these
days? Probably more than uh with all the
new gear, right?
NH.
Oh, NH is cool. I used to be like mildly
okay, I would say.
You know, I'd be one of the guys running
around with like a five, six mil set.
Nothing like nothing even great, but I
could do I could do okay.
Um, yeah, NHU can do. It's like I think
NH is going to look less interesting
though because it's basically just going
to look like AHK, which it is. Whereas
if you do something that's has more
interesting mechanics to it like Doom or
like Well, Doom is actually a pretty
hard one to to simulate. There's a lot
going on there. I started doing I did
this dumb vibe coding stream where I got
pretty decently far into implementing an
M simulator. I think if we just did that
but actually did it correctly, M would
be an awesome one. Doom would be an
awesome one. Hunliff, like Hunliff or
corrupted Hunliff would be a great one.
Uh what else is there that would be
pretty cool?
I think those are like the main super
interesting ones. Yeah,
I guess there are some other ones that
would be kind of funny. Like, you know
how the God Wars bosses have very
precise no damage straps you can use?
Like, I wonder if it would figure that
out eventually, things like that.
Hope the workout went well. Oh, yeah.
I've gotten myself some training
sessions with a stupidly good
powerlifter. Um,
they were essentially I went for like
just a general assessment and they said,
"Oh, yeah, you can book training
sessions by the way." I said, "Yeah,
yeah, of course they're going to try to
sell me on those." said, "Yeah, he's the
state champion, by the way. He's like
the state bench champion." And I go,
"Uh, okay,
sure. Sign me up."
Six to eight actions, dude. Six to eight
actions per tick is still stupidly good.
And like, it's not it's very it's very
hard to model the human delays in that
game, honestly.
NH is fine, though. Now, I do hope you
don't actually plan on sticking it in
the real game. Uh, please don't break my
favorite game.
I use all this stuff for research. I
don't actually use any of it on the real
game. Uh, figure everything out with
some nudging. Oh, yeah. It'll definitely
figure it out. It's NH is annoying
because you have to do scripted whereas
the bosses are just like you don't have
to do the like well is it actually good
if it's has 50% win rate versus itself
you have to deal with that.
I think I'll probably do some more game
inspired environments but not until
puffer 4 because like puffer 3 is good
where it is. Puffer 4 is going to be
stupidly good and it's going to need
some new hard ends.
All right, let's see. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18. So there are
18 observations here.
18 knots.
That looks good, right?
Hey, look at that. It runs.
Doesn't take fault.
Yeah. Yeah. Look at this score.
It's actually kind of doing something
which is funny. Um,
so I have no idea what's up with these
policies. We shall see.
8,000
profit
expense not much
uh with very short episodes
So, we will see what it has done.
I'm going to let it finish training
so we can sort of see and then maybe
we'll like uh we'll kind of put together
what trades it's doing.
Yeah, it's actually funny you bring that
up though, Volter. Um, I had not played
in three years because I've been
building Puffer and then, you know, I
figured I've gotten a lot of stuff done.
Uh, there's the 25 year anniversary.
It's alltime peak concurrent. All right,
I'll let myself play a little bit.
And if I end up playing too much, then
I'll have to take another three-year
break.
Two years.
Yeah, that'll take some time. Congrats.
It's kind of cool how much you retain
your skill as well. Like, it's not like
other stuff where you come back and it's
like, well, I suck at this again.
the uh the muscle memory patterns are
like very very stable.
You know, it's it's such an interesting
game to me because well, one, it's super
fun to play, but then also with the AI
angle of it, it's like it's super
efficient to simulate if you do it
correctly. Um, it has all these
interesting mechanics that are really
difficult for people and feel quite
complex but are actually very like
doable for RL. There's all this longer
term stuff in there that's like hard for
RL but very easy for people
and it's all quite self-contained and
you can kind of like simulate little
chunks of it wherever you like.
A runner too.
Do I have gear for that right now?
I think my melee gear kind of Well, I
have a sight. The rest of my gear sucks.
I've been down to run a top or two.
I've been learning Doom.
I'd actually the thing that I would like
to have more than anything if I were to
choose like one piece of content it
would be at least do the M fight which I
started doing as a sim or if you could
do the entire raid that would be awesome
but that would be a lot
uh sold the Torvah helm yesterday for a
ZCB for um for Doom
all I've got is Bandos for that like
yeah I don't know most of my gear is
locked up in the T-Bo
I swear though it's so it's so weird
like the type of things that are
difficult for um for people versus the
for the RL agents. Like I actually
unironically think that
uh some of the stuff on Versix is harder
for me than some of the stuff on Doom
even though it's like objectively way
simpler.
NH is pretty simple.
Yeah, NH is pretty simple. The thing
that's annoying with NH is the action
space for the um the inventory and such
is pretty annoying.
Doom would be harder. Yeah, full raid
would take ages. I got pretty far into
just doing like a basic of the M fight.
I actually got it to do the um you know
the three to zero cycle on M. I got an
RL to learn it with like my super crappy
vibe coded sim. I I did like this dumb
vibe coding stream because people wanted
it wanted me to. So I said, "All right,
well, we'll try this." And like I got
decently far. It'd be way better if I
just did it myself by hand. Um
I might do that at some point. I think
it's really cool when there's like the
thing that's really cool about the
bosses for me for RL is there's usually
like an obvious way to kill the boss
where you take a lot of damage and then
somebody figures out a zero damage strat
for it, but it's kind of intricate and
then it's kind of cool to just see the
RL and just get it immediately, you
know?
Or like if the RL agent doesn't figure
that out, that's also interesting,
right?
Cuz like the RL agent is not going to
have a bias to just stand there, right,
and be lazy. It's already going to be
trying to kite a little bit pretty much
immediately. And then most of the
strategies that uh most of the
strategies out there are just like fancy
ways people have figured out to kite
that lines everything up perfectly so
you don't take any damage.
So it'll be pretty interesting to see
like know hey those strategies took the
player base many months to figure out.
Can an RL agent do it in 60 seconds?
At least one of our RL agents, right?
Ours are really fast.
Okay, we have this running uh 28,000.
So, what I wanted to do is I just wanted
to do a little bit of uh just add a few
prints in here.
Uh so, we can see what is going to go on
with this.
trying to think what we would want to be
looking for here.
Well, the entropy is super low.
So, I would think that this is going to
be I think I can just print the axis.
How's puffer four? Puffer four is going.
It's hard. We're at 9 mil steps per
second pretty much. Uh I think the next
stream on puffer 4 will be tomorrow.
And we're going to try we're going to
stop optimizing the existing kernels
because that was driving me nuts. We're
going to just write a few like basic
kernels for everything else. We're going
to fuse as much stuff as possible so we
don't have like a million little element
wise ops in our profiler and we're going
to go from there.
That's going to be the play.
Hopefully that gets us pretty close to
tenor.
I do not know though.
Okay, so we have action eight on
everything.
Okay, so it learns action eight for
everything. Cool. Um, action eight for
everything is
indicative of uh it trying to do Hang
on, let me see. I think that's probably
the most it can sell it for. But I think
that's actually a perfect policy against
the crappy scripted agent.
That's nice
because
I mean thanks.
So archive H.
I think it's the perfect policy.
Oh, actually let me see. So it's job
wait price
I actually don't know if that's a
perfect policy. Let's Let's like uh
Should we load this in?
Let's load this in.
We'll load in this as like a a real
buy scenario, you
So, what I'm doing here is I am uh I'm
making a configuration of this in the
CSI that's going to match our training
configuration. And then I'm going to
just come up with a stupid scripted
agent to see how much money it makes.
And I'm going to make sure or I'm going
to see whether our trained agent is
making more money.
Reaction. Did I post the reaction video
on YouTube? I think I did, right?
I forget whether it actually like did
uh
hang on.
agent learn from a scripted agent. It
can, but it doesn't have to. FBR,
I don't know. I probably could do more
on the content side, but it's just such
a distraction from um you know, the
actual work I do. I mostly I stream
because I'm actually at least as
productive, sometimes more productive on
stream as off stream. So,
that making a pop or how to YouTube
series.
The thing is it's going to change so
much in the next version.
like the next version. Honestly, it
makes everything I did in Puffer 3 just
look like stupid toy for babies.
Like
there's been so much work with it. I had
to learn so much new stuff as well in
the process, which is good. It's very
good to have to learn a bunch of new
stuff. Um, but man, it was a lot of
work.
Honestly, the thing that was the most
amount of work that kind of screwed me
was having to do the new architecture,
right? Like if I just kept LSTM,
it would have been substantially easier.
But then the thing is the LSTM call,
it's
like a CUDN kernel, so it's
monolithic. You can't really do anything
to speed it up or to really understand
why it's taking time at all. Um, so at
least now we have full visibility over
our network.
But it took so much work
and it's still not great. Like I'm sure
that my current suck, you know, even
though they're so much faster than
torch, I'm sure they still suck.
We'll probably put some basic bounties
up, you know. Maybe I do something like
um I don't know what's reasonable.
If I do like $100 per percent, you make
puffer faster. Do you think that would
entice people
to make puffer 10% faster? after you
make a thousand bucks.
I have to make sure I actually like have
some rules though so I don't get like
shitty low quality PRs that make a mess
and they are being observed. It's not
what it's not because I'm being observed
though.
It's because like I'm narrating my
thought process and stuff and it keeps
me more engaged.
Like actually
the more you scream, the more it's just
I it just don't care. I'm being
observed, right?
Interactive rubber ducks.
I mean, some of you people know some
stuff, right?
competing against you probably.
Could you They're competing against you.
Well, I'm not a Colonel Dev, dude. I
just learned some of this stuff to make
Puffer 4.
Like, yeah, you're not going to beat me
at making RL good. Sure, but you can
totally I'm very beatable at any of the
individual little things that I do like
little bits of system optimization,
right? A little bit of like bindings and
stuff, CUDA kernel, like all these
little things I'm not great at. I'm just
good at picking up enough of these
things and then I have the RL background
to know how they need to be chained
together into the actual thing we're
building.
It's hard to pro procrastinate. Yeah.
But it's like the procrastination is not
like, oh, I'm lazy. It's I literally
cannot force my brain to work on
something sometimes. It's weird.
It's very odd. Well, it's not even
really odd. It's kind of cool because I
know I'm not just being lazy
um when I can't make myself work on
something just because of other areas of
my life. And you know, you have
discipline in other areas of your life
and it's like, well, it's not like I
just have none in this area somehow
magically.
It's usually just my mind being like um
focused on another problem or just not
having had adequate rest or whatever the
hell, right?
Open source is there to share. Yep.
Can Puffer play Pokemon? Yes, it can. We
have um world first completion of
Pokemon Red with AI.
This is a powered by Puffer project.
Where is it?
Yeah, there you are. There's a blog post
on it.
Did he break his site?
He broke his site.
Well, whatever. There's a blog post
somewhere.
Hey.
Now, I will say there was a lot of
hacking and hand engineering in the
Pokemon project. Um, but part of that
was because the environment is so slow.
Like Pokemon is about a thousand times
slower than our other environments.
So, if a lot of the hand engineering
stuff could have been way more automated
and less hacky if we had reasonable sim
speed.
Okay, number agents
and we're good.
any type of game
you'd recommend starting with.
Um, I mean, if you're new, you pick
something pretty basic that interests
you that we don't have already. It's
kind of tough to tell you ahead of time
what's going to make a really good RL
environment and what isn't because a lot
of stuff is actually very surprising,
right? Like so this slime volley end is
a few hundred lines of code. This thing
is pretty fun for RL 2048 is a
relatively short environment that ended
up being a ridiculously useful for
research. Tetris as well breakout we use
all the time right so try to like do
something you can do in a few hundred
lines of code though you know don't pick
up a gigantic project do something
that's going to be maybe depending on
your skill level two to 400 lines of
code maximum.
um follow our guide, right? Like work
through that and get something that you
can actually have up and running
relatively quickly and then depending on
how that goes like try something more
ambitious afterwards.
Triple triad. That was uh Spencer.
That's a really fun environment. Um I
think Spencer will not be offended if I
tell you that the code for this
environment sucks. Uh this was his first
environment and yeah, the code for this
sucks. Uh, and now like after uh one
year later, he writes code that is like
no flaws. I'd say like pretty much he
writes code that's as good as mine. Um,
yeah.
So, he like did this one and then he
built like a few others and he kind of
improved from environment to environment
and then he got up to where's where are
some of his newer M? So, like he built
this tower climb end. This was one of
his like bigger ones. This is quite
good. It's like puzzle 3D puzzle. And we
collaborated on this though. He did a
lot of the training side work on this
one
and
now he's doing real client work.
So, this stuff can be learned. Um I'm
not going to say it's easy. It's a heck
of a lot easier than it used to be.
Well, there you go.
Didn't need to learn C with Puffer. I
don't know how much I don't think he'd
really done much or any low-level dev
other than like from school beforehand.
He had a CS background, but he did not
have an AI background at all.
Like, he stuck around and actually
learned the stuff properly.
And now he's working on
I believe he's working on selfplay
research uh using the chess environment
that Jess has been building.
Selfplay is going to be a really nice
addition to Puffer. And I kind of just
say that. Okay, Spencer, you go figure
that one out. I'm going to work on
optimizing 40.
My bot learn this. Uh no, you can't
start with Minecraft because the
existing Minecraft game is super slow.
You could write a fast version of
Minecraft and learn that, but that would
be like a pretty complicated M. I think
we do have a tic-tac-toe and like
somebody's PR it somewhere. Jess, it's
so easy though. Like that one is like
that one will just be instantly learned.
There won't really be anything to it.
I think by puffer four, pretty much most
almost all new simple MS that are
implemented correctly are just going to
get one shot by uh the training elbow.
And then by puffer five, the goal is
that pretty much all the medium
complexity MS get one shot by the
training elbow.
Realistically, we're kind of already
oneshotting some mediumsiz problems. now
if you're including the sweeps as part
of the uh automated experiment, but I
think it'll be like really solid and
stable by that version.
job. T R
and
Do you believe? Wait, hang on. I missed
a bunch of messages. Turn-based board
games tend to be
um It depends. It's tough to know
without knowing more sounds. They're
kind of obnoxious from an infrastructure
perspective though, just because like
most of our stuff is by default it's set
up to go concurrent, right? So the
trendbased stuff is a little annoying.
We like low we like um low frequency
concurrent games more. You believe RLP
will gain popularity? Absolutely. Tough
versus alpha go. Uh, that one would be
tough, but I would be very happy if we
got a go agent that's like log linear
and compute and stable. Kernel
optimization fiasco end ended at 9
million steps per second with more to do
tomorrow. 1 million steps to go.
Okay. Does it make 22,000 energy
revenue? Really?
That's funny.
Zero job revenue.
Interesting.
this to like one
actually. It's only It's supposed to be
like 200 gigs, right? I think that's
fine.
P. I don't know what that end I don't
know what that game is.
Our
reward scale is going to be totally
messed up and such.
another card game. No card games. Um,
turn-based games are a little bit
annoying. If you have a scripted
opponent, then it's fine. It's just like
turn-based solo.
We're doing it for chess.
It's just like infrastructure is a pain.
That's all it is. Oh, yeah. What's that
um what's that like multiplayer tank
game? There are a few of those that
would be pretty cool. I've been trying
to get somebody to just finish Robo Code
as well.
Uh, that one would be nice. There's so
many M's, man. There's like so many cool
things you can do. It kind of depends.
Um, you know, like I have a bunch of
cool M's in mind as well, but like the
medium complexity ones I don't want to
give to people who I think are going to
make a mess of them or like the
project's going to be too hard rather
for them to do until they've gotten some
more experience.
Bomber Man. Uh, no. I remember though
that being Palmer Man, right? like the
um that was used singing Resnik's work
used that in his PhD
that wouldn't be too tough to to well
court if that's I think that's all the
agents move at the same time right if it
is then that would be perfectly fine on
our infra
Okay. So, the energy expense way too
high here, right?
Yeah. So, it's just not bothering.
I actually don't know then how it's
making 28 grand
off of this.
Oh, you know what it's probably doing?
It's probably waiting until the end of
the episode and then buying or whatever.
Yeah. So, we got to fix that.
What do I do for this? Warhammer would
be interesting. That's a super freaking
complicated game though. It we don't
want a game where the the freaking
Warhammer players can't even agree on
the rules. Okay.
as the bad
bitcoin.
And I figure what's going to happen most
likely is I'm going to end up with for
the next bit I'm probably going to end
up with a bunch of client work to do as
well as a bunch of work to do on the
Puffer 4 release. And then after that,
I'm probably going to be burnt for a
bit. Uh play some Runescape, feel guilty
about it, and then decide that I should
make up for it by actually implementing
a couple environments based off of that
MMO's mechanics because they're really
good and would be pretty awesome test
environments for Puffer 4. That's
probably what I'm going to do
knowing me.
Does it run on AMD and Nvidia or am I
stuck on CPU? Well,
um, well, definitely trains on Nvidia.
You can also rent 4090s for like 30
cents an hour. I think you can rent
3090s for 9 cents an hour.
And I think some people have it on um on
AMD. At least Puffer 3, they do.
From Puffer 4 onward, we are definitely
developing like CUDA first and foremost
though. Um because it's just such a big
perf boost. Now, if Nvidia decides to
troll and makes their new chips super
expensive or their desktop chips and
like AMD gets better about stuff, then
maybe I change my mind. But for now,
this is how it is.
Or if um you know the TPUs get an
interface that is not that does not feel
like eating glass, then maybe we'll try
some TPUs.
So these all just have to go down by a
factor of
a thousand, don't they?
Base,
let me see.
Oh yeah, because this is now in dollars.
So
point Yeah. So 0.02 would be the correct
thing for this, right?
Yeah. So yeah, we just have our units
wrong because we did the refactor. Fix
that.
What box do you want me on since I got
third amendmented? Uh, no. We're
supposed to still have you on there,
Jess. Can you figure out with Spencer if
it's like
I I forgot that you were on there? Um,
is anybody using uh the box one? Cuz I
can move the stuff that's on that like
the other stuff we were doing on zero
onto one.
The third. Is that the quarter?
It's quartering troops, isn't it? Or
that fourth. Yeah, that's quartering
troops. [laughter]
It's the freaking XKCD. I take the third
[laughter]
Uh I mean you can run Can you just run
stuff on the rest of the GPUs, Jess? I
think the uh it's just a maze
exploration experiments. It's only using
a few like a couple of them probably.
We just have some maze exploration
experiments that are like possibly going
to make it into puffer 5 if they work
cuz I had somebody who wanted to do some
of them who actually competent.
So,
I figured it would be a nice to spot the
compute.
sensitivity and demand threshold. Right.
See how that works? Probably I still
have to mess with it.
So you got the base
uh demand is hang on energy demand base
You absolute buffoon.
Uh, it's supposed to be
So price base here. Yeah.
Demand curve stays the same.
How? So this just goes down a factor of
three. I think just go one, two, three.
Like this. Yeah.
Yeah. Much better.
You dummy.
Well, that's cuz we have a misuples, you
dummy.
Okay.
How's chess going, by the way, Jess, if
you're still here?
I am quite excited for that environment.
Do not let my um you know lack of
supervision
tell you otherwise. I've just been busy
with all this crap. Chess is going to be
such an awesome environment for
selfplay.
for lib can make money for you.
I mean in some sense it does right.
The business model of puffer is that we
build we build custom sims for companies
um that then work with our high
performance reinforcement learning
tools. So you could imagine if Puffer
Lib were a closed source library, right,
where we just had the fastest RL
training out there by three orders of
magnitude that's also way more stable
and has a bunch of other tools and we
said, "Hey, we could build you high
performance sims for your problem and
then have RL on it that actually works."
That'd be pretty valuable, right? So
that's how we charge because essentially
we say you get that plus actually the
library we're using to train is open
source. So you're not even stuck behind
thirdparty API walls. So it's actually
just as valuable if not more being open
source as closed source.
interesting
buff for drone program. Uh we do have a
drone end and we have an intern for the
summer who's going to be working on
drones. which will be cool. We have a
little bit of defense stuff as well. Um,
not a ton.
Should say defense adjacent stuff, not
defense stuff.
All with differentiable rewards.
Uh, I would want to see
I'd want to see compelling evidence that
this makes sense. E10. Cuz like how the
heck do you get a differentiable reward?
Making the whole nth differentiable is
not a good answer.
or in a physical. Eh, honestly though, a
lot of the times we just pick like four
or five things that we think are
relevant at most and then we hyper pram
sweep the coefficients and then you just
have a measurable outcome that you care
about, you know? So, we don't pick the
run that has the highest reward at the
end. We pick the run that has the
highest performance on the metric that
we care about.
what's the revenue just doing this?
It's a low ball offer.
See if we get logs now.
We do
Why is CUDA graph so much faster than
torch compile?
Uh torch compile is just bad.
That's kind of all there is to it.
Like honestly, the amount of trouble
I've had with that thing, it just
shouldn't exist. It's so bad.
It's actually just a case that anytime I
have to work with something written by
an Nvidia engineer, everything is cool.
And every time I have to work with
something written by a meta engineer,
everything is awful.
What does it do to compile? It attempts
to either trace stuff with CUDA or fuse
ops or do a bunch of fancy things. In
practice, most of the time it spins for
like one to five minutes and then makes
your code slower.
Google code. Yeah, I believe you.
Honestly,
most of the big tech companies just are
full of awful, awful engineers
and then they mostly introduce a bunch
of processes to try to wrangle a bunch
of really awful engineers to building
something that they can still somehow
sell.
It's like not where you actually go to
look if you're looking for good
engineering. Though they probably have a
few good engineers that they, you know,
keep in a closet somewhere and they
bring out whenever they really need to
fix something.
or in Hawaii.
I like to imagine that they have a few
full-time engineers who they just pay
year round to be in Hawaii and a few
weeks every year they just say like hey
we need you back immediately. It's like
all right that's going to be have to be
an upgrade for the rest of the year for
Hawaii for me. It's like all right you
you know you'll get your upgrade we'll
send you to the better hotel. Okay, come
back and help us fix our five sep ones
that the intern caused.
[laughter]
It don't work. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Go to pool.
Hey, look. If they're not actually
pushing code, they can't be pushing bad
code. So,
there you go.
Okay, let me think what we do about
this. Um,
if I try
If I just do this, I'm going to say,
"Hey, there's no RNG anymore."
Okay, now you make nada, right?
You still make nada
and now you make a bunch of money,
right? 150.
You still make 150 if you do this. No,
you make less because you offered low.
Okay. So the you should be making 150 if
I do this.
Okay.
So if I just do real quick scripted
by price, I'm going to set this to zero.
visit offices. You claim more people in
at the pools than in the offices. That's
funny.
So you get a little bit of an increase
but not by much. Right? 134
What is the end? This is a cloud
marketplace commerce simulator.
It's pretty cool.
Um, this is for archive.
They decided to open source it and since
it's open source, there's no reason I
can't stream my work on it.
testing options. Uh, it's for pricing
compute. So, like they're they're
training agents that can like buy and
sell compute. And it's it's essentially
like a pricing and negotiation
simulator.
So on this we get 150
and it says we get
it says we do get 150 profit as well.
Buy low, sell high.
Yeah. Well, probably not doing too much
more than that right now, but it will be
doing quite a bit.
Now, RL Sims kind of tend to, you know,
it it takes a while to get the base sim
into place and have everything be
correct. And then the RL takes off quite
quickly though once it is.
Okay, look at that.
So, it's doing the right thing.
You see
Okay. So, actually the policy is correct
and somehow the email is different.
Yeah. So, this is like super uncommon
that it does something wrong.
auctioning compute or are they
building a market?
I can only tell you what the simulator
does. So, it's a simulator of a compute
marketplace.
They may be using it for a variety of
things, right?
I'm not privy to all that, and to the
extent I am privy to that, I can't tell
you about that. But the sim is open
source, so I figured I'd build the sim a
little bit on stream because I've been
lazy. I haven't been able to force
myself to just focus finish it and
they uh they deserve to have a workable
version of this already.
So, it seems to me that we actually it's
learned the correct policy
and um we're somehow like reporting it
wrong or something weird
is what it would seem.
But you can check them out on Twitter.
I figure we'll just toss them some free
advertising.
The stream is not sponsored, by the way.
The sim is like the sim is work for
hype. Um,
but the stream is not sponsored. I just
thought it would be fun. So, yeah,
there's the tweet on the sim.
There you go.
Pretty good.
It's a pretty good,
you know. I think I'm just kind of um
kind of a goober is what's going on
here.
I think we definitely've got a uh
gooberish
streak
because I'm pretty sure I'm just not
averaging,
you know.
Next thing
we are going to try
It's kind of tough to actually do this
off eval, isn't it?
You probably do it all for training.
Aha. You see
134.
So, we've just got a small
initialization difference, it would
seem.
Yeah, it is.
Okay, I did this wrong.
Lo and behold, me dumb.
Oh, I mean you have super stupid
redundant code either way.
Wait, how does this work?
Oh, you so stupid.
That's so stupid. You literally have it
correct right there,
dummy.
That gets us
to 145 with the rand RNG.
Uh, let's see if we can learn it.
Listening while it work. Chest has been
good. Found an end plug that was super
obscure. Nothing would affect training
practically, but still need. Nice.
Configs are finicky. Sweeps do not do
well with ELO. Yep. Nice to see.
Intuition about chess poor light with
hypers and selfplay. Higher gamma
smaller material reward positional
rewards. I convinced we can do pure.
Yeah, you can eventually do pure
terminals. I think Jess, you're going to
be able to have something where you enal
off of material
would be my uh my main guess, right?
You do get 145 just off of um
interesting. Always picking zero
or always picking two.
If I just get rid of this.
Do we do a better
level two so weak. Well, what ELO is it
though, dude? Do you know roughly what
ELO is?
Is it better than I am at chess?
Feed previous reward is an obset better
for credit assignment. It depends on the
environment.
In chess, you can very easily learn the
correlation. Anyways,
and this is a little sketchy without it.
Okay, so it matches this thing
uh it matches this thing
without domain randomization and
slightly worse without it.
1100 better than I am
better than I am at chess already. So
nice.
We should add back in energy sales real
quick.
It's not that hard. I know that they
actually care about those quite a bit.
uh maybe I'm silly. I feel you could
apply to stock market and yeah, you
could.
I mean, we've done some finance work as
well.
Oh yeah, there's a lot of cool stuff you
can do for sure.
I don't know. markets like stock markets
aren't as interesting to me unless you
like paint a wizard hat on the side. Say
you're selling runes. So basically, if
you make it a MMO market, I'm suddenly
interested.
That's how my brain works. I don't know
what to tell you. [laughter]
There's not much outplay potential here
yet, but it's solid.
Okay,
there we go.
That is a uh a solid chunk of work. How
do you keep Runescape away? I don't,
man. I stopped for three years. I
downloaded it again.
But to be fair, I um
I uh I think I'm in a pretty good spot
now where I'm not gonna just be like
playing RS constantly because Puffer's
actually got a lot of velocity behind
it. So
like the fact that I actually have
everything on a roll now is good.
Um, but what I did for the last couple
years is essentially I just put all the
like all the spare time into fitness.
And I'm still spending a ton of my spare
time on uh on fitness, but I'm rehabbing
a couple little injuries. You know, I'm
doing some shorter distance training
where I don't need as much volume.
Yeah, I'm chilling.
Anyways,
all we have uh well, I mean, all we got
to look at now is uh the quick little
outro.
Well, you dev. No, I shouldn't FBR.
Um,
yeah, for folks watching, I stream all
my dev. I'm going to be doing some
kernel optimization, probably converting
some stuff, um, some torch ops to
kernels tomorrow for most of the day.
We're going to try to hit that 10
million step per second training on
Puffer 4. If that interests you, if this
interests you in general, please just
take a moment to star the repo on
GitHub. We're almost to 5,000 stars. It
would be awesome awesome to hit that.
And um if you want to get involved, join
us on Discord right here. This is where
you can contribute to dev. Follow me
extra more RL content.